amateur d'antiquités vous êtes au bon
endroit voici l'ancêtre du vélo
d'appartement un véritable home trainer
des années 1900 il était principalement
utilisé apparemment dans le
Transsibérien pour que les gens puissent
se dégourdir les jambes il y a plusieurs
systèmes de réglage et il est sur un
châssis bois toute la partie métallique
c'est notamment la fonderie et elle est
poignées sont en écailles de tortue et
en noyés un peu plus loin Bruno Herpin
tient à nous montrer un autre objet
exceptionnel de sa collection un vélo la
française diamant utilisé pour le
premier tour de France 1903 avec le
guidon moustache et la petite lanterne
pour l'éclairage mais pour le
propriétaire des lieux le véritable
trésor ce sont ces vélos eliets l'une
des marques emblématiques des années 50
et 60 elle a été fondée ici même à
Sully-sur-Loire et yet c'est aussi une
équipe prestigieuse aux multiples paris
sportifs au milieu du XXe siècle et ils
vont nier le Tour de France Espagne
Italie champion du monde sur route sur
piste et trois titres olympiques ça va
être Jacques Anquetil qui a gagné trois
tours de France sur Elyette André
dargade René Vietto qui a été coureur
cycliste et directeur sportif de la
marque en trois ans et demi Bruno Herpin
a collecté plus d'une centaine de vélos
et constitué un véritable petit musée
dédié à la marque ce passionné veut
mettre en avant le patrimoine sportif et
industriel de sa ville c'est hyper
important de faire revivre ce passé et
toutes les personnes qui ont participé à
l'élaboration de la marque Eliette et de
la faire revivre et la faire reconnaître
surtout au niveau national le musée
devrait s'agrandir en 2025 la nouvelle
salle d'exposition sera aménagée dans
l'ancienne atelier de l'usine 60 ans
après l'arrêt de leur fabrication les
vélos ELIET sont prêts pour une seconde
vie